Building little demos is fun and
all, but building a real game
is a whole different beast.
It's like assembling a fine watch,
there's so
many moving pieces to keep track of, and
integrate, and so many interactions have
to be frictionless,
lest the whole thing grind to a halt.
And guess what?
You've done it.
You've brought Gigigal to life in all
her platform jumping, cannon shooting,
robot destroying glory.
I can't wait to see how you choose
to extend what we've built here.
Will you add a level select screen,
add new types of enemies,
add different types of
weapons maybe a boss battle?
The possibilities are as endless as
your imagination now that you've
got the skills to bring
your ideas to life.